the other time I thought about you was
uh the death of Taylor Hawkins I know
you had seen him a few nights before
Taylor Hawkins the Foo Fighters the
drummer who just died before actually
he's been on my show a million times and
uh loved this guy just another
good-hearted Soul great musician
um you know amazing too even you know I
know we know him from the drums but has
an amazing voice too actually I want to
share a story about what happened two
nights before when
we were in Paraguay and a monsoon
happened essentially and our shows got
canceled and it sucked because that day
was the day that the Foo Fighters were
playing with us on the same stage and I
texted Dave and he was like yes I'm
gonna come watch the show and they've
never seen the show and that was the day
like oh my God the Foo Fighters are
going to come watch our show so we went
to soundcheck just to like sharpen up
and we had built speakers uh just so
that they when they're watching from the
side they could hear the the show fully
and we were so excited man and um the
rain came and I saw lightning start
happening and I was like oh my God
get a call the Show is canceled that's
our show and the Foo Fighters show so
it's canceled and uh I'm texting Dave
and we're super bummed
um he's like well you know come come
over to the hotel or we're gonna shut
the rooftop down and we'll have some
drinks and we end up going over there
and
you know I look at us in the lobby and I
see we're like 20 deep
so it's a lot of us and I'm like oh God
I don't know like
how they're going to feel when we all
come up there all this stuff like that I
don't know if it's mellow or if they're
gonna be like oh why did why are you so
many people and I walked up and we got
out the elevator all 20 of us
and
Taylor
Dave the whole Foo Fighters team and and
but specifically Taylor he went up to
every single one of us and gave us each
Our Moment Like every single one of us
man like down to my assistant they were
relating over oh you're from Topanga
from Japan it was just like dude he is
oh he's such a beautiful soul man and he
I remember he was talking to me about I
played Tommy in the in the motley movie
and he was talking to me about how he
was at the premiere and he was like oh
man the way you did Tommy's mannerisms
like oh he's he's the man huh we were
just relating on that and he was uh
I told he was so proud of his kids and
he was so like
he would do he was so bright like he he
came to all of us and we were watching
we were tripping out right like we were
looking at him like through this glass
and he dude he stopped at every single
person
yeah he was a beautiful guy he gave his
heart man and I uh that's a great story
I just want to say like
to his kids like your father
when we left there
you know like the the kids and US came
out we were just like
this is the greatest night of our life
like these Legends like in in the last
thing
that he had said and my drummer was we
were tripping out over he was just like
the last thing that he had said to him
he was like I'm just so bummed I didn't
get to see you guys play
and um
I uh
I I really want to
I really want to thank him and let his
kids know that he made us feel
in a time where the outside world
outside of the fans and outside the
outside world was really coming in hard
on us
and he made us
feel so confident in ourselves and loved
and your father is a great
great man
and we are all Lucky to know him